I had no idea until recently
it's a kind of survival videos on
youtube there's something like that knowing versus
because I couldn't even fritz
meinecke what did I miss there now
listen in a
warm welcome fritz my clemens
fritz 9 I'm excited so it's an
adventure  for or yes i think that
describes it quite well because i do a
lot of different things and
you can sort that camera into one of my divisions
and adventurers it can be
anywhere you could also say
youtuber because i have youtube is a
big channel exactly yes  there we are
people follow a
little over 1.8 million do you have
a word but it was all about getting there right
away not quite as
predictable you are originally from
magdeburg and did you once
start training as a
car mechanic
yes you did  but I also stopped very quickly
because I was only two months that was such
a bridging sting I was there I
then noc  h
got my high school diploma then passed my technical school diploma or
technical school diploma is somehow
not like that now means i’m the
practical type now i
have to somehow slip in here all
training has already started
well let’s do something with cars then
i’ll be a truck bus at some point
landed on a
freeway you can probably imagine how it works there
and then I
quickly said we need
a reset here and then I
was gone again very quickly if
you did a suitable bank clerk
apprenticeship in Stuttgart he  because
comma you lie euro in his ditch in the car
and somehow the oil drips in
it it's cold wet disgusting everyone
isn't that nice to you because you
somehow have to admit it outside
neckarwiese was in december and
then you think wait a minute  is
the opposite, well, bank clerk, good,
that's economically solid
, you can  starting with and
building on that, the train of thought was
really real and then
I said yes, it's not like that
, I'll take it with me now, but like the takeover, I'll take
a little bit of practical experience with me,
that I already have a little bit of that  what
is solid knows how can tick
off but noticed so i had to
do something else the only problem was
i didn't know what
and back then there was still
compulsory military service nine months of basic military service
and i thought something like that is
actually clear i'm for it  Now register
voluntarily because then they ca
n't just pull me at some point
if it doesn't suit me, that means I
thought it will come is that it will come
at some point anyway then I'd rather look for a
selection now it fits right now
then I said I'll
just use it again  to
reset completely it is a part that i have to
do and then i can use the
time and think again  to do and
well,
that's what I did then, then I found out about the
various vocational training fairs and
you have to say, at that age
maybe I was
somehow 18 and then at 21 like in the
Bundeswehr 22 like we're
32 today  I just had no idea
what, how, where I couldn't say anything,
what do you want to be, I don't know, I didn't have enough experience, I didn't see enough
,
but it was so very clear and
precise, and then I went to the trade
fairs and saw  that there is
also something like
computer game development in
germany
i learned to be a 3d graphic designer for
computer game development so in the
end you can actually
imagine a digital craftsman
i created digitally be it
textures with photoshop be it 3d models
if you imagine a computer game
I actually
built everything there that you see there in 3D, except for
characters, animals and stuff like that  s in that
direction, i have
cars, weapons, benches, a cupboard, a table,
a cup, so everything that is
created in this digital
computer game world has to be created somehow and that’s exactly
what i did until
my studies started i then
extended my basic military service i think
for
15 months 19 months i don't even know
about going seamlessly into the
training and you know that
at some point that was after the
armed forces last proper training because he has this graphic designer and what are you doing on
youtube weigh that what's going on on youtube
you there in the channel made
the first videos were actually going
place videos so leave places that I
explored you I didn't
speak there I just
made recordings that cut each other
music underneath so more
what was not in the end and then it happened
gradually more built up was
just fun for me I
originally started with a  he started the facebook page
where a few pictures were already
posted, i wrote a little bit about
it and then i
realized i somehow want to
show more of what i experience and
i can do that with every video from the
best i have  I have moving
image material I think that's the
most perfect way to
document and show something and that's exactly
why I started with it and
then I introduced a flashlight to
mam and
then I talked a bit into the
tours  then i also
tried out new things looked for someone
small
shelter in the woods once slept outside well all sorts of things I had already set
this all up in parallel during
my studies and then at some point I
realized that it would be really cool to
maybe help finance his hobby
too  Was there such
a genre back then as author videos or bush
crafting survival? That was back then
already clear that there is such a job yes
that was clear so you have to say
that i myself have changed from a viewer to a
creator i have
already watched these videos from
other channels myself and
found the team always very
exciting but  noticed that he does
n't have any
respect for creighton at all but i always thought that nobody could do
that either so you
do really cool things there but in terms of
film technology there's still room
for improvement so that i can somehow do it
better
and then tried to
do better and what you had the videos that
got really rich for the first
time so what did you do there is
for the first time saw 200,000
watched today
I actually think that was
crossbow video yes there I have  I
didn't start
testing stuff like that, which was fun, like
a knife and an autograph, and then,
among other things, I was really keen on
bog  shoot and close amos
i think the first video that
went through the roof a
long time ago was actually a
review of such a crossbow
okay you kind of ordered it
and then just started shooting in the forest in the
end yes so they  I have that
I think was also such a cooperation where
I don't have so I what's on
loan so here you can have
you can have a look play around
there have to send it back
and roof truss york so obviously why not
yes quasi free advertising  done and
didn't even get anything for it
and you just
showed them a bit and presented
different tools shot tests done
at different distances
I think said a bit what kind
of performance they had how difficult it was for us and
that was the first time that a bit
on the other hand, you can unfortunately do it well
, everything is complete, I have the first few
years completely everything completely all
one power yes and how did it go on then
so the growth then came out
stronger on youtube exactly so
growth definitely always came
most strongly from youtube all other
platforms even today be it now
instagram or back then facebook
always came over in the end  youtube was
the people coming to youtube
who got a full big big
content package really
what was in it and then just said
navy cool now by looking at what
else is doing there a little bit or
small updates and yes  I
sort of started at some
point to finance my hobby with it, to the point
where you can buy a backpack
, like a new knife or something,
and that was still because of
my studies and I did my studies in Neukölln
in Kaufland in der Wolke  products
department worked nice cheese
sorted with yoghurt etc.
of course to add a bit of yellow
to verdi while studying  enen because the
studies cost him money like for
the magics and within the worked
and you can see the point where i thought it
would be really cool he
has 2450 euros basis if i
eventually earn so much with it that
i have 450 euros  thank you
i still work
for a year but invested the time in
my own project which i enjoy a lot more and
i don't have to sort which
yoghurts yes and that of
course took a while
but then I got it done and that was
the first step  and and then
that was the youtube proceeds or
that was youtube proceeds but i
think most of it
was offered by amazon at the time because of course my
everything I did there is blatantly
equipment-based so if i now
like to sleep outside then i have a
backpack i  I have a cooker I have
an insulating mat sleeping bag so you need
it for all these car umpires
you always need things so close and
I then simply linked them via
a completely normal loses commissions
program from amazon so always put our
youtube under our the video
the links exactly the links down
i then started
to create equipment on my website
to create categories and so
on  have made reviews of certain
things and shown what I can
take with me or what namely on a
cleaning lady watch with what namely to
what I have used for the adventure
and now not so crass
advertising space bold moderate but the
people were interested in it so it  it was
always like that, i
didn't do it at first either and the comments
borkheide wegs Messer borkenberge where
which backpack is that what you use so well
i have to pack underneath anyway
because the people here know everything
and that's what i started with
earn some money cooperations
have you ever seen his adventure is
off d  he anvil so you
experienced that for adventure i did a lot of lost
places so just
looking at me and
did a variety of small trekking
tours so if you
basically fatten multi-day hikes and but
sleep outside so basically
live out of your backpack yes of course we are
eat a little bit of water
but where else does it beat or
do kilometers outside and you're just
outside in nature and you would
have to walk around in germany
exactly the first tours i did in
germany i then did
the gr 221 in mallorca that's at the top
in the north the sierra de
tramuntana mountains that i am completely
won that are 130 kilometers and
exactly and in 2016 that was then but
i was already self-employed that was the
first year of my own i was there
for another two years completely together
from munich to venice  walked
that was the first big big long
adventure 23 days  ge were on the road 550
kilometers 20,000 meters in altitude that was
once completely about
always sleeping outside and like on
the tour we actually
slept in huts you have mountain huts and those
were the big videos directly so
what or what was the biggest so far
video is the most successful one has
to make it clear to everyone what you
're doing
I actually have to check if I
like to know now was for years it was
a
a video where I
built a shelter but a
bit in the asm first wo  i haven't
spoken and that
's why it's had international power since before
it's now four years
old has 5.4 million views that you got
this primitive technology hype so
maybe a few people noticed
over the years that he built this
whole temple even though it was bauhaus
have been shown a little bit everywhere
and it actually originated
from the australian or something like that  he
just built the huts with his bare hands
using primitive
technologies and then i made a
fan video somewhere and built a little hut
here in germany with just my hands out of
dead
wood with
some kind of roots as  ropes and that
was the best video for years now
i actually saw that an
episode of sap versus wald my last
big project cracked the whole thing
and made 5.6 million views
after only a month
we can say that you
now everything  that's how you do what you do on your
journey he had someone taught
it the whole thing somehow
works again that's how it works you did
it the most natural self-made you
drew on it
yes that's actually really crazy because
meanwhile i know a
lot of people who like that  in this
topic you can ask me
what i exchange but when i started back
then  no matter which
step I didn't know anyone I did
n't know anyone who was self-employed I did
n't know anyone
who made youtube who knows how
a website works how to make
video editing so I didn't have anyone
who could help me in any way
how it all works, so
that's why  yes, how did i teach myself all this little
by little, be it
via youtube tutorials about learning by
doing, also read books for podcasts back then,
then there is the whole
entrepreneurship then how you handle
the whole thing, someone tackles a
projector when projects  structured how to
make to-do lists yes that has
nothing to do with youtube
but also with general
self-employed work and
since when have you been doing this
officially full-time since 2000 16 ok
and then it was clear you deserve
it  a lot of money that's enough is more than a
job in the supermarket and b more than
a right  ger office job afterwards
because they are all a bit
different for me i did my
training in 3d graphics i said i built it up in
parallel and then you
found a job in berlin where i also
worked and i still did it in
parallel like that  and then
i worked and thought to myself
at some point a
bit wisely i got the
tip from calvin hollywood maybe also said
what he always said
you become self-employed full-time
if at some point you earn as much as being self-employed at the same time
as in your main job
that's why it's okay i'm pushing it
on like this it's growing a bit from month to month
and at some point maybe
in two years i'll have exactly as much
as i earn my job here right now
and then i can go into full-time
self-employment because then i'll have a
lot more  time and then it fits yes yes
that was the theoretical plan didn't
work the company had i  ch was called
a special meeting
publishers skipped filing for
bankruptcy that was it from one
day to the next i thought so
[ __ ] this is not going according to
plan here but it was immediately clear to
me i can’t apply anywhere else now
so i just
don’t feel it  i don't feel
like setting up any job interview now and wanting to
tell someone or
sell yes your company is so great i
'm really interested in it i have to be
i'm not i want to be
self-employed i want my
own boss all the time for mine
make videos document my adventures
want to
make videos and then i wrote a
business plan and
applied for a start-up
subsidy bz what am i, i just went
into unemployment for a short time after the
insolvency and from the unemployment so to
speak i applied for a start-up subsidy
the  since then it has also been
approved w  ar i think on the first of
march or april i know 2016 and
then it was clear to me i'll get it for
six months i recently saw that the documents that i
looked at were 1200 euros
or something like that i got a
job for what was on youtube  I
've already earned a bit and then
I thought to myself, okay, I now have
six months to work my ass
off and after that I have to stand on my
own two feet and that's what I did, I
was missing 14 hours of work a
day, there was nothing else
and  then it worked somehow,
but then came the columns from youtube
and amazon, which is exactly where there
were already cooperations, so
I also
earned a little something through cooperations, but
only small amounts, but then it
all sorted itself out a bit
youtube a bit of cooperation i had back
then that was also in 2016 i
got a tv order for six
episodes so there i was  it's
nice if you call it that together with wigald boning
there was the
show like geld und fritz the story
seeger on the history channel and since i have a larger
project where it was six episodes ok as well as
shooting days budget where i already have a
little bigger one  had my first order where
i noticed okay we have a little
something we can save ourselves every year
and then yes it came one after the
other bit by bit and where have you got to
now
where have i got to now so now
economically it’s like that  as if
you owned this company of the
company right now it's working big and successfully
yes so economically
i can't complain i've
been wondering for years when will the increase
stop so because i always have feelings at the end
of the year then you pay attention to
it  I don't follow that too blatantly,
so I don't look at
any tax statements every day. I
don't feel like it, but then I look
at the  more and then see which
evaluations also from my tax consultant,
who then always puts the
last three years
next to each other with diagrams and imagine that it’s
ok now, but now it’s
calmer at first and then
I’ll look later, if it’s available, I
’ll help  the fish that means you are
one of the famous youtube millionaires
or not yet
i think i'm doing very well okay
but i think i'll feed that the
entire so redeem from youtube but
also from amazon from cooperations and so
on you order amount yes
so  of course because in the meantime
i have your own online shop
raw products are sold via it which of
course name company does for me the
ground floor is
so yes everything is going very well
for me but it is a point where
i can invest in new things again
so  in new projects
in larger projects in trips
that are sometimes significantly more expensive, so I
always say that  what money i earn
that gives me freedom and
flexibility for myself but of
course also for upcoming projects that
i can just prepare awesome
what your greatest cooperation there you give
i have now read as is if you
briefly on wikipedia that somehow
that  duo emmi lived in a
mercedes-benz g-class for a while i
assume that we also paid but there is
no more time
for a film i spent a lot of
money for but i have to
buy the car and convert it but that is
not  been a cooperation mercedes or
sun ok ok the
biggest cooperation is difficult because
that's the point that i
have more or less long-term partners in the end if
i would probably add
them up that was my greatest
cooperation is it logical if now
another hate thing became maybe
one  cooperation partner has the very
good conditions which pays off very well
but of course it is anyway
great to have someone who you have
by your side every month and even if
it's not going to be that much but
just over the months and years
who it is I
would say knows erfurt is definitely
my biggest cooperation partner
and but such an idea  we with
mercedes i my type i
think everything is clear here too
cooperation when installing the city car above
is the permanent car in front of 400,000
people but that doesn’t give
you any thoughts about that you would
ultimately let
us know in advance and  I'll ask if you'd like to ask
me that too,
because it's a bit cool to
add it doesn't matter to her, yes, because I'm not a friend of
cold calling, I hate it, so I
'm I'm never the type of numerous
companies go and say  so he
wanted it like that
but i'm waiting for the company to approach
me because then i'll have a basis for
negotiation honestly mercedes he
doesn't care that much a  Apart from the fact that this is an
old Mercedes from 2005, a
commercial vehicle, military variant, they
don't sell it at all, so
someone couldn't even
buy it later, of course, it's obviously
image-wise for Brent, it's
cool for them, but no, that's also
you  also crass a dependency
so at the moment so I have to
get some kind of car, whether it's a
Mercedes or the vw opel nissan
mitsubishi whatever it has to be, he
knows, so I'll just do the advertising like a lot of what's
up to date  per week
last year or vice versa for the last few
years i always did one video per
week but
i sort of finished that a few months ago i basically
only do my
projects now and then i publish them
and that can be like in november
and  december 16 will follow so two
videos group will come out that
can also be like now in january that
has two videos out a month
let them come again shortly before he
comes to the projects say
there was something else on youtube you learned
you maybe can
imitate somehow you can pass
it on you have grown up always
the content is of course awesome ok
long hikes path  builds blatant
things so what but were there any
lever procedures that
want that but that got
me quite a lot that
wasn’t so clear so first of all everyone who
somehow makes youtube wants to start
or something else
the point is already number one the
basic motivation is your passion  your
basic motivation why you are doing this don't
let the money stay is a
basic motivation i somehow have a
great hobby i have a passion
for something be it horseback riding ballet
dancing drawing rapping adventure
is a good
basic requirement you need a
passion for something that you later use to
earn money  deserves everything cool you can with
it there too  after earning a lot of money
but that must not be for my taste
must not be the basic motivation
secondly youtube or social
media in general probably generally
self-employment is a marathon that is
that it has to be clear that it
just takes a long time and during this
time it will always happen  There will be sprints again
but there will also be breaks and there
will perhaps also
be a setback for my injuries and that you
can describe it a bit pictorially so it
's just taken me a very long
time I can somehow say now I
'll do this here for two three months and
then it runs and then put it
back no well first of all you could you
have to keep doing it over and over and over and
over so that’s why the
passion for it and the motivation not
the money and a clear there are also
sprints says okay now here’s
a video  right dismantling now I
still got the full subscribers
but there may be auc  h once again
months like a summer slump probably
nothing happened where the views
slump where a topic is not well
received and that's just normal
that's completely normal of course you can
analyze it a bit you
can react to it but you
mustn't let yourself be frustrated by it  you
sometimes but content i would have adapted a
bit according to the taste of
the viewers so first
noticed okay they are mainly into
something like that i make of it it is a
mixture so the point is and
i have also learned that for me you have to
do it on what  you're keen if you
do something just throw the spectators
keen you won't be unhappy you can
tell that in the videos you don't
really feel like it the motivation isn't
there you can tell his gestures facial expressions how you
speak
it's okay if you maybe watch a
video  does where you say he
doesn't feel like it, but
i'll do it because the community
wants it  It's true that but that should be
the exception
it should be that you're keen on
what you do and there were, for
example,
points on which I was
super keen the video technology wasn't well received then I
didn't make any more videos of it  I
still did the things but
didn't film anymore as far as I
said I'm still there I
still want to do it what my
message was for example a
day hike back then
I think so I like to be where
I am sometimes  say when i'm somewhere
abroad now i'll pack my rucksack
and now i'll go to the summit
nice day hike look a little
me enjoy the nature up there and that
's fine again but that's
a bit boring for people if
they just want to be outside  and stay the night
and fire and it wasn't really
great [ __ ] for several days so I
do everything but then I
decided I'll just do it  rhin
everything as before but i'm part of a
film i don't hold the part for me
so you shouldn't bend yourself too much
for the viewers that's very
important
pointing it out to the colleagues
everyone who listens to us here regularly knows that
because I agree  we are also allowed to
have a very small share in
the company at mr what the
colleagues from premium do is
real-time market research within
minutes you get representative
answers to your question so you sit
in a meeting and ask yourself is the
slogan cool  understand that people
want the business model to be viable that people want to
use or somehow test something like
that with api million very large
companies are already doing this red bull vw
lidl beiersdorf and also the day when they own tokyo if
you want to try it out send a short mail to opinio doppelpunkt
com  and you can then
start the first survey right away
[music]
which is now a platform like you tube and
it's even been talked about and
then it gets loud again since you're
80 active exactly twitch since I
've been a little over two years
now there is a second youtube channel fritz
meinecke live where the
highlights from the streams are played
exactly  yes in the end youtube
is for me a bit of this high
quality why my club small
tv station like that instagram is
kind of a bit yes currently
something like that besides a bit of making-of
behind the scenes plus a bit
anti saw what was happening what  I have
projects this that & witsch is a
bit paired one question is that
I just watch videos and give
my opinion on them because
maybe it's interesting which
ones I don't watch videos myself because I
might learn from it myself to
draw new creative energy and  not
just we have her fun he makes the
spectators too and I also make
a bit of an appearance  n gaming but that's
it, that's really the way it is, I just hang out
with the people so there's
no concept behind it, there's nothing that
won't be played on the
tube again, that's easy, I want an
election round, I'll chat with you a
bit  and the boxer can be there
how many people are watching the
entry so when it goes live again of
course everything is live how many
are there i streamed
eight and a half hours yesterday were a
peak power 5500 and we were after 1
1 30  driver still 1700 or so
okay what have you made intervals i watched
the first two games i
watched videos on the subject of
survival cleaner author of various
stuff so what i also do only from
attackers and the remaining six
hours i played daisy and
daisy wouldn't say that maybe doesn't
help is keep going a
survival simulator so you could
say that the only goal at sea
is  to survive as long as possible
and you have you can fish there
you can hunt there you can eat there
are other players you can
have a nice chat with the players i you
can but also
so that's why
it's like a yes why a building set
why lego  box and what you
are doing there and what you intend to do there
are no rules so there is just
a reason mechanics a box and
then you are simply in this world and
then you can think about what you
are doing you okay I got that  already built
faster and small oven and
you somehow look at a few thousand
people who were feverishly there
and little has to do with what you
do that thailand the stars or he
can help someone
do a quick research on the internet how to use this
oven again  needs how many bricks do
i need it was what you tool to dismantle the
bricks euro minister comes
one of those cut off i should see if he
has the friendly  he system in the head
that was how big
you appreciate a community so now
between 18 million who
have subscribed to the youtube channel and 5500
who watch a touch screen is
a big difference so what can
I say that you really see the real
community  microsystem where from then that's
a matter of definition what is the
real community well if you're just
watching i have 1.8 million
subscribers but it's for example the new
episodes that have 345 million views
then you know watching even
more  mendes are subscribers but
there is a hardcore community that is
always there there is also a
community that has been there on
twitter whether instagram there are any
on youtube and instagram so
that's how it is very difficult to
describe a few hundred thousand people
are already  longer on that can
say to each of you related to youtube
yes well the point is yes on
twitter we have yes well me  i have 200
250 thousand subscribers but kills is
always live that means the person has
to have time right now and be up for it
now so on youtube he
can see that entry if i
watch it later in the morning the day after tomorrow but
if i now  look at youtube kuckum
apart from the last big project
, my videos actually always had
three 400,000 views, so i
would say that you have a community
of three 400,000 in any case
and let's say the old
calculation still applies, kind of like a
million  Views of around 1000 euros
are
in advertising money I
've never heard of the bill can
I have to calculate the numbers now
whether that fits or not which is the
point you have a purely
advertising income on youtube which lured directly from
the platform  still almost like
a cpm and it changes, so you
can have cpi from three to four
and then you have november and dec  ember
then you might suddenly have one out
of ten so then you suddenly have
a big project and you book advertising partners
directly only on your channel
then a cbm is suddenly at no
idea 15 so it fluctuates back and forth
that means you can’t do it like that at all  so
mixed but that's
more attractive for you what youtube about white
or meanwhile the direct
cooperation
the cooperations are always what
is actually stronger and that the
last project was also i think
with a partner that was financed that's
really crass now  done what
I did again are as hoped came
across at least what matters because
that is this format that is wild that
's your latest expansion stage, so to speak,
exactly that was something completely new big where
I said to myself now let's leave the
problems out now  what's
new here what's very big complex lots of
consequences team in the background
actually that's what i'm doing hal  t
never used to and was keen on it and
now has the
network contacts in the background
to be able to implement something like that and then
we did it and then we see what
exactly is that holds what should
escalate exactly everything is more or less about that
even 27 candidates would be exposed for
seven days with only seven objects
completely isolated from each other in
sweden
who now know 16 episodes
everything can also be published on my
youtube channel can watch everything in peace the
episodes are going yes it's
a bit like television moderately
from the production point of view, with
graphics applications, narrator intro and
yes, in the end it is about seeing
how people react in an
extreme situation, so of course
extreme for some, not for others, but
if you ask the normal one, i'll say
seven things to take with you and there
By the way, there is no tent, no
sleeping mat, no food, no drinking and we're
chic  now with these seven
objects just get out into the
wilderness for seven days completely
alone almost magic
you can use something in an emergency that goes wrong and
you still have a phone that has been switched off
and sealed if
you can call if nothing works anymore  i
think that is an extreme situation for most people
and it was nice
if you put the seven so we will you
have all of them if you exactly i was
one of them and we have six others
and mixed that right so we have
people who are familiar with it
but we also had a mountain biker with
us we had someone with us
who actually had no
contact with it at all he slept like you would
a hammock and you
somehow rode your bike through the tent this time
but otherwise really
had no plan and it was
n’t about a colorful one  to
have a mixture because if you now let me put
seven experts in there
it's long  because the point is for the viewer
to see ok watch out
now it's going to rain and wind how will the
wehrmacht react what kind of mistakes food who is
what so who knows the mushrooms who
knows from the bärenberg fishing
the power he that it would be successful if
i  everyone deals with the
isolation so that it becomes a little more
exciting, there were also daily
challenges for each day, which then had to be
completed in order to have a
nice comparison among the
participants and in the end it
lives on the different
emotions and  how each
participant reacts to it and i think what is very
short for the viewers is
why the success has to come everyone is
somehow feverish and
said his favorite character okay i think it's
cool bot he really annoys me and everyone
doesn't know better but you
also think about which ones  I would have taken seven items
with me if I had taken my storage there or
the motto was not  I took
a sleeping bag a tab the
plane a three by three meter plane only
a knife that but a very special
have to look to make it a bit bigger
like a
pot set and a jet of fire
exactly and the other six you chose
everything yourself so you had  you
who and so that's exactly the point
i was looking for people i
know personally just in case the first
project was of this magnitude and
i wanted to have people i
can trust where i can just
talk to them then and then
do you have to be there you have to get there and there
i need that and that
from you then i know okay i trust the people
i have already done
something with them or they are
friends who fit in there bypassing the kempen
camera that's
exactly what we want  only with only
men,
unfortunately, yes, I also asked a woman
, I only thought of one
at the time, who I thought capable of
but unfortunately she didn't
dare ok and did they get money for
it but that's just because you
want it so that was we didn't
get any fee or anything for it it
wasn't my goal either
somehow a fee motivation for
taking part  I was
more concerned with the fact that the motivation to
take part is something that people
really want and that is not
based on money
and, above all, something has been
created there, so you don't have to
say we had in the background or like
a paramedic
in the motorboat
we had something we could get out of it we only had
the rescue team in the background and so
on that means being able to do something like this at
all with
a security pact in the background
you don't have the opportunity at all
so there's nothing at all  did it
cost him to produce
something like what you described everything
describe the whole city
feature  s and film evenings
so we had
planned roughly 75,000 euros i think we
also had 10,000 euros for the winner
for charity so it could be
donated exactly 75,000 euros
planned
but it turned out to be more actually
okay okay so it’s maybe 200,000  yes
something like that and find is told
everything is a one partner there was a
company that said that that brings
exactly today so we will have rainer is there
as a partner who makes hardware
things like that you have a cell phone cases so
basically the safe end in the vehicle
continue
and of course you have to think about it now
so when you see the numbers
and when you see the budget then
you think that was a shot in the oven but
you sold yourself completely below
value so when you see the millions of
views which you don't
forget  may is we
went to this partner with half a sheet of paper
he says they have an
idea we want one like that  big youtube
series make 16 episodes so a bit of
survival we put a few people out of it
and yes we don't need a clue so
several thousand euros so you're quite up for
it so if you look at it in
retrospect and how
everything that happened then looks like
everyone says racists here like several
hundred thousand euros if i even
more but you mustn't forget this
idea came about with a few sentences on
an a4 sheet of paper and so
you go and look for someone now,
for example, we have a comparative
project which is online  is where we can
show look at what we did 16
episodes happened to us there and we
expected it but then foot numbers they
're so blatant that that's exactly what he
fixed video made six million or something like
that 5.6 million yeah that  is
that i had already contacted a tv station
or something meanwhile
it is also somehow why is it now
in hiding on youtube ready  something
for for rtl 2 vox so much about the or
not
two here no idea
maybe very briefly so you are
important that the whole
thing is a real authentic thing and more
documentary and no trash tv where
which children were but
to get back to the question  to come
there were a few inquiries now of
course afterwards i still have
talks and video crosses with certain
tv stations agencies
production companies these are of course partly
things that are somehow about the
second season or
other projects but also very own
productions with me with me as the host
somehow to implement
whether something will come of it i don't
know but it's not my focus either so i
've talked about it several
times i think that sky
should do
it on youtube there is currently not
really a reason for me why i go on
tv or even
should go to streaming platform so i
don't know why i should do that because i
on youtube i'm my own boss
i can do whatever i want if i
say the video is 43 minutes if
i say video is an hour 15 bum
done if i say [ __ ] the project
will be different we'll do 10 more instead of the 16
following 10  that
doesn't work at all with a tv station but
still in the fix you wouldn't
be tempted somehow
the numbers with 10 bits definitely so
why so was why should i
go there what's the advantage of it
except now clear if it's financially
tempting  but then the question is also do
you need the money what do you want to do with
it so there is another project
was it then invested for it so clearly
this topic now netflix and co is of
course always a bit of
a
pat on the back i have my own netflix awesome like that  you know that's a
bit
of a résumé prestige but purely from the processes in the background the
freedom of flexibility youtube is
the best thing I have  I can have I
can do what I want and I have planned
this whole series with
max and johannes who also do my live
channel together and
we have a whatsapp group and if we
discuss costs because we
want to change the title or the words
written in spanish at all i would have
i don't have to go to the station manager
then i don't have to go through 10,000
contracts and need two weeks to make
any decision but
do you think that the
motorization is not unimportant
and I mean the budget you were once  what
you get from your streamer or from
the broadcaster
is also knowledge decide what
you can do internally so what
possibilities you have and of course what
you earn with it in the end and that's
what people just got
engaged but you say  in the end i
can with youtube i have more
freedom and can certainly
do a lot and that will be financially i  It's
so good that I can do everything I
'd like to and also
earn enough at the same time, so that's the point
I've still earned money with it
through advertising revenue, I'm also very
happy with it
, it's also because of the calls that are
generated by there, so that's that  closer to
millions of more than 16 followers so
i can't complain
and no idea you just
say to get a feeling for the
overall sap investors project because there
he is to youtube a cooperation that i'm
sponsoring here so everything
together we'll go  of
several million who could know about the Abitur
but several hundred thousand yes yes yes yes
yes yes okay but then it is now
at least like that if
now imagine if there was a
vox or something like that that
they would be ready already the one the  get children with
television advertising a lot more out of
it, pay accordingly expensive, purely
theoretically,
just think about it, yes, from the theory, so
I h  but yes, I've often had television
inquiries and somehow something in that
direction but what I've
experienced so far television
is so badly paid so
all my orders I somehow had I
've done everything I've done on television
because I'm up for
it  and because I said it's
really cool for image pictures and you
know what's on TV, etc. but
all TV things also inquire, etc. there
was never anyone has never had a financial
background
somehow
for a tv three days of shooting where i
am abroad with a departure i get 400 euros of
which i give 200 euros to the
state and i got 200
euros because i was on the road for two and a half three
days then i pay on
top of that i honestly say so  Nah, I'll do
the math now,
but it's really a cool project, as
I said, I'll do it anyway  all good
but purely financially television of
course but in the end you can see
what you're doing there you'll do that forest i
hope that's okay done so the
analogy to the angel kempe what
button and stuff like that do there those are all
projects that come from the  yes say
youtube.com and
all of a sudden they are being produced like a tv show where content is really being
created that is significantly more than what
a person is really
doing the action companies or are behind it and
we say we are now doing the big
event tv is really like that  highlights
moments so you notice
remembering what absolutely so an angel
camp was there at the first one
or all the other events that were there they
are all from the streaming area
is a completely different story
because everything has to be done live
live quasi cut cameras switch
correctly in the background is a
completely different number receiving internet
and so on but yes  you generally notice
a change like that
and i think it's awesome and i think it's cool
that i've shown this change
on youtube now, too, because
honestly if you normally
think of a youtube and what we did there with
sam is broad
practically against every rule
youtube videos short crisp ten minutes
no idea sometimes 15 comes with us from time to time
we do the big 16 follow tyler with
you go at least 45 minutes to
an hour since he says every
normal person like that yes but not up
youtube i don't know that it
doesn't work and people
celebrated it but yes because they
saw it too we're getting
a full-fledged
series here somehow that could run on dmax netflix
sky whatever traveling amazon prime again and again
and we
just have  on youtube we just need to
click on this link on
top of that you can watch them all how awesome is
that because
what did you do before that  what's next
yes there are now two
smaller projects that i'm
just keen on and then
in february there will be another bit of the biggest
project the small tour motto so
just go for 56 days
i know that i don't have anything i either  I
don't think I can do it yet and I ca
n't spoil it yet but yes I'll say
it like this I can only say so much is going
abroad it's a multi-day tour there
will be mountains there will hopefully be
unlit you run exactly it's on
foot there will be 120  kilometers 8000
meters of altitude difference
there will be a lot of ups and downs
it will be warm it will maybe
still be rainy everything is possible everything can
come I'm up for it it will be
completely and that's exactly what
nature is in the end it's not just almost a
bit too now  I want to hear it almost
normally when I was just
talking about the meeting about two you had
there but brought up such a blatant thing
with the tension and  all of
these elements and now you're doing in
leader stretches only nature over 120
kilometers between almost somehow
almost over home use
you can come up with that still in your head
so yes i know what you mean of course this
isn't the next big
thing you say okay  a
second one doesn’t come, of course, but that
doesn’t even mean my intention
to start because I want to do
what I have sport at all and if I
’m in the mood to experience nature,
to challenge myself physically,
to show an epic landscape outside on
peaks  crashing like looking at the panorama
with a blatant sunset then
I want to do it like that maybe it's
not for everyone which is also completely
okay but that makes me happy at the end of the day
I'm up for it if
I'm only earning half of it now like
I earn with the other video is
actually quite honest and the
clothes projects from the local spoke
dor  t can you have water there is now,
for example, winter be back
this month so there is white only a
two-day tour with an overnight stay where
I will be
in the mountains at about
2000 meters and then there in the snow I
are smaller the alps or have to
exactly that is a story that
i want to do then i have a
tactical skis course
vettel is also with me and exactly where
we then stop from movement close
certain reloading things exhibition
out lying down sitting and saying
that's a two-day course  which I still
take with me then I was
n't out there right now at the beginning of the year of the video
because I spent four days in frankfurt
in the mm spirit which made by hart da
nl done with
exactly the four days of
saving made stand stand training bot
training and therefore will also  video of
giving this is currently in the cut
and exactly when I the Bundeswehr
time for you a bit so
don't show me  listen shoot
fight a lot of what you took with it at
the moment it's still helpful for you the environment is actually
not easy at this point in time
I haven't done it yet it's very, very
funny because from the current point of view you've long
thought to yourself something exactly
that what  fit in and bauer before
learned something and took it
with me but at the time when i was in the
armed forces i
didn't have much to do with this so
yes i was out a bit
and did a bit of geocaching
but that's how it is  all these things that would fit in there now
they are actually
only parents who came later the british
seem to be the top sponsor for your channels yes
there were already one or the other project
in the planning by the Bundeswehr
which was canceled every time
but sometimes
I don’t need it either  So because because the Bundeswehr is one of
the biggest cramps what any
agreement
approval
the mills de  r the offices grind slowly,
so you know, if you don’t do much with
any normal company,
then what do I talk to about something and
then it starts, and at the Bundestag it
’s about five corners and the press chief and he
still has to get permits
, no, no, we can’t  seven days so there are so
many rules and guidelines and everything
doesn't work and you can
only make the videos like this we all
have to watch them beforehand that must not be shown
that may be shown you have to
do that now we're going to build the test
50,000 applications filled out me  I had myself
dressed completely and then
not again I think it was so tight
then it stays I just wrote a
little pun on it our partner our
but with a set
so our is our partner that’s the name of the
company and the helping dealers dealers
actually do it  everything
to enable customers to have a
unique shopping experience
and now there is someone
with them  our holding of the company that also
takes care of the dealers themselves is
above all paying for the whole thing our
has built a flexible all-in-one payment
solution and is the one stop shop
when it comes to payment solutions on the internet,
and ours
supports children from card terminals  up to all
common digital payment
solutions everything you need on the market is no matter if big business or startup our has the right package for you take care of like with panda red bull decathlon tamaris many
many more are already working with our
always think about the right spelling
and all something  above all things
between us very much as and he wrote
and very point com / better
we are this rhinow squinting people came across
you how did that come about
that is our concept in the westerwald
exactly i had a
cooperation with them years ago quite normal
further  a whole new video to say
has been featured and so on
and then we had last one  s or
penultimate yes, before that we had
two smaller projects, a two-
day project where we
asked them spontaneously and they
all went through again, the
projects all worked well, they were
great things and then I said
that  that means you can i now
probably also hear a lot of people
who tend to always be looking for new
ways to advertise so if
someone does something with you i mean it sounds as if you weren't completely covered with major sponsors you [ __ ] open for
to be business so what can you deliver then
yes well i am of course always
open i know you too felt like
2000 mails a day for which vacuum robots
and led showers lead
very very grateful
yes well i like my partner
best of course who is somehow cool
fit in so everything he wants
goes into this outdoor area or something like that is cool
rainer shield protects also protects
again  r a mobile phone when you are out
and about is also a part of
a car product fits super clean was
young I have the insurance